[Musik]
sie stehen für Raub Schutzgeld
Erpressung Körperverletzung und
Drogenhandel
kaum eine arabische Großfamilie steht so
stark im Fokus der Ermittlungsbehörden
wie sie der Berliner Remo klar
eine verschworene Blutsbande bestehend
aus 1000 Mitgliedern wenn ich an die
Schwere der Taten denke wie Goldmünze
auf der Anklagebank sitzen vier
Angeklagte denen der Diebstahl einer
Goldmünze aus dem Berliner Bode-Museum
zur Last gelegt wird und grünes Gewölbe
in Dresden der Gesamtwert der
entwendeten Stücke wird auf über 113
Millionen Euro geschätzt klassische
Geldwäsche Immobilienbesitz und so
weiter das zeigt für mich ganz deutlich
dass diese Familie keines Gruppe keinen
Anstand kein Respekt vor unserer
Gesellschaft hat
der remo-clan lebt nach seinen eigenen
Gesetzen der Rechtsstaat er wird
ignoriert bei ihren kriminellen
Geschäften erbeuten sie Millionen legen
es weltweit an in die hootellerie zum
Beispiel rund ums Mittelmeer fließt sehr
viel Geld wir haben es dort nicht mit
rational denkenden Menschen zu tun
sondern die verschaffen sich
größtmöglichen insbesondere finanziellen
Erfolg durch möglichst wenig Aufwand den
sie betreiben Geld sichert den Remus die
Macht in der Hauptstadt und das über
Generationen die Strafakten der
Familienmitglieder beginnen bereits im
Kindesalter wir haben etwa 23 Straftäter
mit fast 250 Straftaten wir haben schon
damals immer wieder festgestellt dass
Kinder mit Einkaufslisten losgeschickt
wurden in die Einkaufszentren und auf
Bestellung gestohlen haben
ein verschworener Clan der rücksichtslos
mit seinen Konkurrenten umgeht
notfalls mit tödlicher Gewalt an diesem
Ort wurde ein brutaler Mord verübt
dieser Remo und die Familie Remo gehören
ohne jede Frage heute zu den führenden
Clans unter den arabischen Großfamilien
in Berlin
[Musik]